Chris Anderson : William, bonjour. Content de te voir.
William Kamkwamba : Merci.
CA : Alors, on a une photo, je pense ? Où est-ce?
WK : C’est chez moi. C’est là où j’habite.
CA : Où ça ? Dans quel pays ?
WK : Au Malawi, Kasungu. A Kasungu. Mala.
CA : OK. Désormais, tu as 19 ans, c’est ça ?
WK : Oui. J’ai 19 ans maintenant.
CA : Il y a 5 ans tu as eu une idée. Qu’est-ce que c’était ?
WK : Faire une éolienne.
CA : Une éolienne ?
WK : Oui.
CA : Et pour -- quoi -- alimenter quoi -- pour l’éclairage, tout ça ?
WK : Voilà.
CA : Donc tu as fait quoi ? Comment est-ce que tu as construit ça ?
WK : Après l’école, je suis allé à la bibliothèque,
et j’ai lu un livre -- " Utiliser l’énergie ",
et j’ai trouvé des informations sur le moulin.
Et j’ai essayé et je l’ai fait.
(Applaudissements)
CA : Donc tu as copié -- tu as fait la copie exacte du modèle du livre.
WK : Ah, non. J’ai juste --
CA : Que s’est-il passé ?
WK : En fait, dans le dessin de l’éolienne dans le livre,
elle avait 4 -- heu -- 3 pales,
et la mienne en a 4.
CA : Dans le livre il y en avait 3, la tienne en a 4.
WK : Oui.
CA : Et tu l’as faite à partir de quoi ?
WK : J’ai fait 4 pales, juste parce que je voulais plus de puissance.
CA : OK.
WK : Voilà.
CA : Tu as testé avec 3, et tu as vu qu’avec 4 ça marchait mieux, c’est ça ?
WK : Oui, j’ai fait le test.
CA : Et en quoi as-tu fait l’éolienne ?
Qu’as-tu -- les matériaux que tu as utilisés ?
WK : J’ai utilisé un cadre de vélo, une poulie, un tube en plastique, qui ensuite pousse --
CA : On a une image de ça ? On peut passer à l’image suivante ?
WK : Voilà. L’éolienne.
CA : Et donc, et cette éolienne, ça -- ça a marché ?
WK : Quand le vent souffle, ça tourne et ça fait du courant.
CA : Quelle quantité d’électricité ?
WK : 12 Watts.
CA : Et donc, ça allume une ampoule pour la maison ? Combien de lumières ?
WK : 4 ampoules et 2 radios.
CA : Waouh.
WK : Oui.
CA : Et donc -- (Applaudissements) -- image suivante --
qui est-ce ?
WK : Ce sont mes parents, portant la radio.
CA : Et qu’ont-ils fait -- tu avais 14, 15 ans à l’époque --
qu’en ont-ils fait ? Ils étaient impressionnés ?
WK : Oh oui.
CA : Et donc quel est ton -- que vas-tu faire de tout ça ?
WK : Heu --
CA : Que -- je veux dire -- tu veux en construire une autre ?
WK : Oui, je veux en construire une autre --
pour pomper l’eau et irriguer -- irriguer les cultures.
CA : Donc celle-là devra être plus grosse ?
WK : C’est ça.
CA : Grosse comment ?
WK : Je pense qu’elle produira plus de 20 Watts.
CA : Cela pourrait alimenter le système d’irrigation de tout le village ?
WK : Oui.
CA : Waouh. Et donc tu parles aux gens ici à TED
pour en trouver qui pourraient t’aider d’une façon ou d’une autre --
à réaliser ton rêve ?
WK : Oui, s’ils peuvent m’aider -- avec des matériaux, voilà.
CA : Et quand tu penses à la suite, à ta vie,
tu as 19 ans maintenant, est-ce que tu --
tu t’imagines continuer avec ce rêve, travailler dans l’énergie ?
WK : Oui. Je pense toujours travailler dans l’énergie.
CA : Waouh. William, c’est un réel honneur de t’avoir à la conférence de TED.
Merci tellement d’être venu.
WK : Merci.
(Applaudissements)